so wie die ließ was ja weit hinein
problems erste problem ich bin zu cool
zweite problem ich musste mich gerade
richtig motivieren um dieses video zu
drehen und dritte problem muss das video
noch schneiden und heute ist freitag
aber naja ist halt so nah und die
anderen 36 die probleme fallen mir gar
nicht ein
mal
hey was geht ab herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video und zwar ist mir in
letzter zeit war so ein bisschen
aufgefallen das ist einfach extrem viele
vorteile gibt die man als frau hat und
ja ein paar mehr aussuchen die würde ich
euch ganz gerne vorstellen ich bin
gerade so ein bisschen außer puste weil
ich hier alles aufgebaut haben merkt ihr
vielleicht unter wenn euch das video
gefällt das noch unter und jetzt viel
spaß also ich würde ihn nochmal sagen
wir fahren mit vorteil nummer eins an
warum auch nicht möglich sind auf jeden
fall ja ist ja so dass wenn man eine
frau ist man weiß auch auf jeden fall
dass das kind was man nachher vielleicht
bekommt auch wirklich sein kind ist ich
meine stelle sich das mal vor als man
ihr könnt das ja eigentlich gar nicht
direkt nachweisen müsse erst ein
vaterschaftstest machen oder wie das
geht aber erstmal so aufgefallen
irgendwie und dann würde ich mal sagen
machen weiter mit dem zweiten vorteil
und zwar ist ja so dass frauen
beziehungsweise mädchen so lange wie sie
baut auf dem bad verbringen können weil
das ja halt einfach so ist die dürfen
das unfertig das ist doch eigentlich
total unfair ich meine wenn ich jetzt
alleine schon zehn minuten auf dem bad
verbringen sagen war ich dusche zehn
minuten dann krieg ich danach schon
ärger weil das im bad so warm ist und ja
toll macht man kunst die fenster auf
dann ist es wieder okay aber verstehe
ich nicht und als nächstes was auch vor
allem der film titanic so ein bisschen
wieder spielen ich denke oder ja ich
glaube schon das ist immer noch so dass
frauen egal jetzt ein schiff untergeht
oder ein hausrind frauen werden einfach
immer als erstes gerettet und das ist
doch wieder total widersprüche ich meine
warum werden denn frauen von männern
gerettet das ergibt keinen sinn okay es
würde schon in der hinsicht sinn ergeben
dass wenn halt irgendwo ein schiff
untergeht dass die männer dann noch
gebraucht werden um die frauen auf die
rettungsschirme zu bringen oder wenn ein
haus brennt dass die männer dann noch
gebraucht werden um die frauen in diese
feuerwehr dings rhein zu tun aber
obwohl stimmt dann ergibt das dorf sind
aber ist natürlich keine frage auf jeden
fall den vorteil für die frauen und da
mithalten vorteile so fertig so vorteil
nummer vier ist ich bin jetzt zwar nicht
gerade der größte aber ich will mit
meiner größe eigentlich so ziemlich
zufrieden aber bei frauen ist es ja
wirklich so wenn du jetzt wirklich klein
sind dann können sie sich einfach
irgendwelche schule nehmen wie bewegen
sollen absatz haben und dann wirken die
gar nicht mehr klein sondern halt größer
und das können wir nicht machen ich
meine wie wird das aussehen wenn ich mit
solchen schuhen hier stehen würde ok
können jetzt meine hier ist nicht sehen
die ich eigentlich immer trage aber ja
doch besser so natürlich sagen wir
machen weiter und zwar mit vorteil
nummer 5 und zwar ist es ja so wenn
männer jetzt beispielsweise ballett cool
finden dann ist das einfach mal mega
schwul ist einfach so ne könnt ihr mir
bestimmt alle recht geben wenn ich
schreibe es in die kommentare
auf jeden fall wenn frauen hingegen
fußball cool finden dass ich mit fußball
auskennt dann ist das wirklich cool und
das ergibt auch überhaupt keinen sinn
warum das überhaupt so ist nicht mein ja
ich weiß es nicht schreibt sie in die
kommentare wenn ihr dazu irgendeinem
grund wirst ich habe auf jeden fall
keinen gefunden und das ist natürlich
auch wieder ein vorteil für die frauen
mädchen ist auch vollkommen egal und
frauen über mädchen halt mit frauen oder
so ähnlich wenn ich mal so darüber
nachdenke ich glaube ich habe in meinem
ganzen leben noch nie eine frau aus
meine tante gesehen die schon mal den
rasen gemäht habe ich mein ich muss
andauernd den rasen mähen aber ja wie
gesagt eine frau habe ich irgendwie noch
nie beim rasen gesät das sind immer halt
männer und rasen ist mega scheiße und
langweilig also seid froh dass ihr nie
den rasen gehen müsse weil ich kann mir
das nicht vorstellen dass mädchen zu
hause das ding gesagt wird
estefania mima den hafen das würde mich
jetzt gerade mal so richtig
interessieren ehrlich gesagt ob mädchen
so zwischen 11 vielleicht auch acht ich
weiß nicht wie alt ihr seid und 18 oder
so ob ihr zuhause von euren eltern
gesagt bekommt ja mit jetzt mal den
rasen treibt das mal bitte in die
kommentare das interessiert mich richtig
also dass auf jeden fall ein kommentar
sonst sonst bin ich traurig das nächste
kann ich auch eigentlich wieder
überhaupt nicht verschiedene warum das
so ist muss wahrscheinlich irgendwann
mit der gene oder mit der natur zu tun
aber auf jeden fall wenn man mal so eine
arbeit schreibt oder eine klausur dann
das ergebnis bekommt dann sind mädchen
eigentlich immer um welten besser als
die jungs und weiß nicht warum das so
ist ermöglichen ist es nicht ganz so
extrem das sind oft die jungen stärker
aber schriftlich wäre ich auch gerne mal
gut und dann kommt man auch zum 8
vorteil und zwar ist es ja so ich hatte
das auch schon mal früher in irgendeinem
dinge die mädchen an jungs ich möchte
nur noch anderswo video angesprochen und
zwar ist es so frauen können einfach
oder mädchen können einfach nur wollen
und das utah ist so dass sie ab und zu
mal heulen wenn ich es freuen würde dann
würde wahrscheinlich jeder denken was
ist jetzt mit dem nicht ganz richtig
gelaufen noch so gucken stehen beim und
ja also seid doch froh dass wir ein
mädchen sei in dieser hinsicht weil ich
war eine echte sehr oft einfach mal los
ja heute übernachte das video gefallen
hat dann würde ich mich natürlich über
einen daumen nach oben freuen wenn ich
vielleicht auch ein zweiter teil machen
soll oder so könnt ihr natürlich in die
kommentare schreiben auf jeden fall ist
hier nochmal instagram eingewendet aber
hier nicht vergessen wir nichts mehr
verpassen wollen danke für 40.000
abonnenten habe ich jetzt gerade
irgendwann erreicht im verlauf des
heutigen tages und hier auf der linken
seite geht's weiter mit dem ms da habe
ich ein paar von euch angerufen bei
megabits ich könnte ja mal vorbeischauen
und hier auf der anderen seite dinge die
mädchen an jungs sich verstehen oder
andersrum irgendeinen teil davon keine
ahnung ansonsten sehen wir uns dann
nächstes wochenende und ihre haut rein
leute